tu es le rêve américain
[Applaudissements] Des
caravanes de Rags to Riches aux manoirs que
tu bouscules [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
sois
calme, je vais juste faire ça
[Musique]
Je te le dis en ce moment, ces gens
ici évaluent si ou  non, tu l'
as toujours,
je m'interroge juste sur les strip-teaseuses,
elles sont en train de la feminer avec les
flips, les dips et le
canapé,
tu es trop distrait, essaie de bloquer
tout le bruit,
je suis désolé, qui es-tu, je
vais  tu vois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu ressens ça en ce moment oh non merci je
pense que je viens de tomber amoureux de toi qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire qu'il reprend la
maison, il lui a fait un lavage de cerveau
Pas un être humain
tu es une star
[Musique]
ne fais jamais confiance à un mec avec une queue de rat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]